Joe period we are here to do the white
on a complete interview yes we are it's
like I feel like Jim Vanna White is
maybe she's before your time most people
are
there's stranger things based on true
story yeah actually it is based on a
place in Montauk New York called camp
hero
there was like rumors of secret
government spies like doing these human
experiments to fight in the Cold War
oh I shouldn't say it's exactly what's
happening in stranger things and so it's
based on that one government lab in
Montauk New York which is a real place
you can go visit but you're not allowed
is stranger things appropriate for a 12
year old I'd say so
man I couldn't even watch like men in
black when I was a kid why did to your
yeah I thought it was terrifying you do
watch jaws yeah man that I was like 14
teeth yeah et scared me I saw it as a
kid just was thing depends on the kid is
stranger things by Stephen King
yes no it is not no no is inspired by a
lot of his work Stephen easter-egg of it
when Bob is talking to will in the car
he says he lives in Maine and he says
there was this clown that tapped me oh
they didn't say it was penny wise but
they didn't say it's mr. bald oh and he
would talk to his dreams every night
oh no you just get to the bottom I'll
hold this one hey stranger things
dungeons and dragons dragons that's in
it so these are real searches that
people yeah this crop is stranger things
is it good for kids is it cleaned a
little bit of unsanitary yeah and you
hold the board I'll rip the tags is
stranger things in Spanish they can be
can be you can put Spanish subtitles is
stranger things jumpy like you're
watching and you go oh there are a few
good jobs here definitely I think
music is easy to make very well that
makes it jumpy for me is Ranger things
inspired by it I feel like the kid bike
yeah I think it has like some elements
like the monster yeah later in the book
you kind of find out that there are
shiners yeah he's wise do you know I
mean I love that even if this one is
stranger things like The Goonies a
little darker than your knees I gotta
say yeah not as playful definitely
elements of everything I think yes it's
like the game yes it's like to answer
the you know okay next board is Joe
carry that one is Joe carry oh my
god okay I'll take this one sand the boy
yes is that even possible
no mother board I like these yeah I like
this game skate Matarazzo
no yeah no better answer ladies ahead
there better as though uh not the
actress but my mother's name is Heather
man right I was gonna say that is your
mom's name my mom as an actress named
Heather madarao so and everyone's like
is his mother no didn't even know that
yeah next next hitter the vegan no next
worth it yeah yeah did any like worth
watching the show or is it like is he
even worth being on this planet okay
judge stranger things get stranger
things things get better
and guys I think season two in my
opinion is better than really yeah I do
I like it a lot better I think you get
to know more about the characters and
everything
yeah especially I like it favorite this
season really your cares of my favorites
really next the stranger things pass the
Bechdel theft I'd like to believe it
does well I don't know why it wouldn't
know no one of a sadie's character she's
not talking about like a man the whole
time she's like badass she talks to 11
first split second and says I've heard a
lot about you also 11 Mike may I think
it passes strangest things cut yes I
never I just say swear or curse I never
liked the word cuff it's so first season
you only can say cinema swears and they
saved them all for you guys like I was
always like is it cool if I say I like
what the hell here and then I can save
you
does Netflix air at midnight no the
strangest at midnight
no so yeah is Joe Carey related to Ben
Schwartz no I love the guy and we do
look similar but we're not related
it's fury dating yeah are you dating
well I think I'll just have to leave
that up to mystery because that's what
it's all is Joe Curie and a Domino's
commercial that was my twin goal next
question is Joe Carey still in post
animal the boys are touring around I've
had some work obligations but I still an
active with the band and writing music
is coming back from where I would assume
to the show and the show it been the
same without you so is it getting better
so famous I think I don't like the F
word great joke what do people Susan
again I think they're referring to the
fact that I am
the only ones who hasn't a kiss in the
show it sounds like no oh yeah it's like
why is it nothing about willow I don't
think we'll the gopher bomb just
strangest things I've been told that
stranger things ukuleles okay you're
gonna you're gonna answer this what does
it mean something I don't know does
Jenna know it can be scary sorry
the stranger things filming location yes
yeah shoot me an email I can send you
all the filming location isn't that the
cast filmed it in Atlanta yeah they're
everywhere outside pretty much yeah